l'actualité de ce 29 mai c'est aussi
cette plainte déposée par HF prévention
pour propos homophobe et menaces de mort
nous sommes en ligne avec le président
des chefs prévention depuis Villepreux
bonsoir Jérôme André
merci d'être en ligne avec nous
aujourd'hui devez plutôt être un jour de
joie pour la communauté gay avec cette
union à Montpellier qui d'ailleurs vient
tout juste d'être prononcé d'être
célébré donc à Montpellier si vous nous
suivez en direct il est un peu plus de
18h et pour autant il y a eu beaucoup de
mesures de sécurité de prise et vous
même dans les Yvelines vous rapportez
des actes violents plus de 20 tags
homophobes sur un lieu de draguer c'est
tout près de Saint-Quentin en ligne
d'Yvelines que cela s'est déroulé que
quels sont les inscriptions qui ont été
découvertes et de quelle manière vous
les avez découvertes alors
sur le bitume avec ce qui a été le plus
choquant c'est effectivement donc les
menaces de mort avec donc
au four ou encore donc
il faut tuer donc les bébés ou des
choses comme ça et c'est vrai que pour
le coup on a très vite remarqué qu'il y
avait des inscriptions du guide ou
encore des jeunes catholiques qui
étaient présentes et ça c'est juste une
amitié ce qu'on peut noter surtout c'est
qu'elle est donc des triangles rose et
ce qui est important et que les gens
sachent c'est que les triangles roses
étaient à l'époque donc Titler pour
marquer donc les homosexuels et les
envoyer donc encore de concentration
donc on se rend bien compte que dans les
Yvelines c'est en train donc de se
cristalliser on a de plus en plus
d'agressions verbales ou donc
pour qui
sinon on sent bien que la population est
quand même très énervée contre les
homosexuels je rappelle que
effectivement le le mariage vient
d'avoir lieu donc ce sont unis c'est un
mariage comme un autre on peut plus
parler maintenant de mariage gay c'est
effectivement donc un mariage pour tout
le monde c'est un site ce site dans les
Yvelines sur lequel vous intervenez pour
des dépistages rapides du sida notamment
est-ce que vous allez suspendre vos
activités
alors pour le moment effectivement on a
préféré donc ne plus intervenir avec le
camping-car qui est quant à lui marquer
HS prévention donc on vient plutôt en
voiture un peu classique on continue à
faire de la prévention et de
l'information
issu là et on rassure surtout les
usagers qui sont assez traumatisés donc
quand même de la situation mais qui
n'est donc
on aborde non plus de laisser faire les
choses et de laisser aller d'ailleurs on
a déposé une plainte au niveau donc
d'achève prévention et le salut les
efforts donc
Clément généraux qui ont pris les choses
tout de suite en main allez
renseignements généraux de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et aussi la police
donc de plaisir qui est tout de suite
venue constater prendre la plainte ça
c'est quand même effectivement très
intéressant de voir que les pouvoirs
publics se mettent quand même en ordre
de marche assez rapidement dès demain
nous saisissons aussi donc le préfet des
Yvelines pour
lui
pour éviter effectivement donc des actes
donc homophobes de cette ampleur quelles
sont les réactions justement de la
communauté homosexuelle à la découverte
de ces de ces inscriptions est-ce qu'il
y a un vrai sentiment de de crainte
vous-même d'ailleurs vous avez reçu
personnellement des menaces de mort
aussi oui tout à fait nous ça fait un
petit moment que ça dure personnel je
reçois des menaces de mort donc pour
l'instant tout va bien cela dit on peut
être que indigné en colère de voir
effectivement resurgir donc des symboles
du guide qui est un groupe muscule
d'extrême droite on peut être que en
colère de voir ressortir des symboles
donc comme le triangle rose sur la
déportation homosexuelle et à un moment
donné on vous demande bien ce que
peuvent avoir dans dans la tête ces
gens-là qui effectivement continuent à
être agressif homophobe alors que de
toute façon la loi est passée et que si
ce sont de bons républicains ils
appliquent la loi j'aimerais juste pour
conclure votre réaction peut-être que
vous demandez aussi aux politiques de
mesurer leurs propos je pense à
Christine Boutin par exemple conseillère
générale des Yvelines qui suite à la
palme d'or des CERN er à la vie d'Adèle
ce weekend l'histoire d'une jeune femme
lesbienne a déclaré nous sommes envahis
par les Guess ce sont des déclaration là
qui qui selon vous peuvent entraîner ce
genre d'actes ensuite sur le terrain non
mais de toute façon
ça fait des années que c'est comme ça ça
fait des années que Christine Boutin
fait en sorte que ses collègues
politiques aillent dans le même sens
c'est juste le plus possible un moment
donné ce style de personnes devraient
être condamné d'ailleurs on appelle le
MP à condamné donc les propos de
Christine mais pas seulement et vraiment
vraiment il faut que les trois publics
s'empare de ça elle n'apprécie pas
effectivement que les gens la remettent
en face quand des gens parlent de son
mari elle propose d'ailleurs de les
attaquer tous en justice elle a été
effectivement enfin attaquée en tout cas
et on lui a fait remarquer récemment
effectivement qu'elle était qu'elle
était mariée avec un cousin germain
voilà
c'est ça exactement mais en l'occurrence
la semelle de la vie privée des gens il
serait il serait peut-être bien qu'elle
soit une bonne républicaine et qu'elle
se disent que la loi est passée et qu'on
en arrête là moi je rappelle quand même
que sur les lieux de rencontres
extérieurs que HS prévention court nous
avons essentiellement ce qu'on appelle
donc des HSH c'est-à-dire de bon père de
famille qui viennent effectivement sur
ces lieux de rencontre pour rencontrer
d'autres hommes donc à un moment donné
il faut juste que les choses s'apaisent
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça il
faut bien que même temps se dise ce
n'est plus Gérard c'est plus tenable
c'est et puis de toute façon c'est de la
discrimination donc la discrimination
c'est condamnable et d'ailleurs à chaque
prévention a décidé de Rennes de déposer
une plainte à chaque fois qu'il y aura
des agressions verbales physiques ou des
propos homophobes parce que
effectivement même dans certaines AD
ministrations se trouve aujourd'hui
confrontés à des gens qui se retrouvent
en position de faire de l'homophobie ou
de la transphobie ou encore autre chose
donc c'est plus donc demain vous allez
interpeller notamment le préfet des
Yvelines suite à cet argue que vous avez
retrouvé sur l'un des lieux de rencontre
du département de la communauté
homosexuelle je rappelle que vous avez
deux heures et déjà déposé plainte merci
Jérôme André association HF prévention à
Villepreux d'avoir été avec nous en
ligne alors que je vous le disais si
vous nous suivez en direct vient tout
juste d'être prononcé le premier mariage
entre deux hommes en France tout ça sur
fond de tension vous l'avez compris à
travers toute la France et notamment
dans le département des Yvelines